un calme inhabituel dans cette école de
l'île vivent
sur le tableau la date du 23 février est
toujours inscrite
le lendemain l'évasion russe forcer les
enfants à rester à la maison pour suivre
les cours en ligne
mais il reste quelques écoliers des
enfants déplacés par la guerre ont
trouvé refuge dans cette école comme
maria qui non seulement apprendre ses
leçons this may mange et dort aussi
entre ses murs
je m'ennuie de mes camarades de mon
enseignante de mes grands parents et mon
école nous dit elle
savannah il ya dont la guerre finira je
retournerai immédiatement à kiev nous
explique-t-elle
mais l'école en ligne n'est pas adapté à
tous les enfants cette travailleuse
sociale accompagne david et anatolie
dans leur cheminement
ils réussissent tous les exercices mais
parfois ils sont désorientés raconte
elle
la guerre a chamboulé la jeune vie de
ces enfants déplacés mais ils en parlent
peu
psychologue travaille avec eux c'est par
le dessin que les enfants expriment
leurs émotions
une manière de rester au fait de leur
état d'esprit parce qu'ici les rappels
de la guerre sont constants
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la cloche
l'arrêt des cours
[Musique]
encore une fois ici la gala
les enfants connaissent par coeur le
chemin jusqu à l'abri
une fois tous réunis ici sol madame
mathis tente de réconforter les petits
la directrice est le pilier de cette
école devenue un refuge pour la
trentaine d'enfants et leurs familles
helvey à tous même aux vêtements pour
les écoliers
elle nous raconte que cette fillette
n'avait rien quand elle est arrivée avec
son père
ici tout le personnel met l'épaule à la
roue
l'enseignante de musique chante des
berceuses
d'autres enseignante cuisine trois repas
par jour
les journées sont longues nuits sont
courtes
la jeune maria elle ne peut s'empêcher
de penser au moment où elle va retourner
chez elle
va bien se terminer nous allons rentrer
à kiev
et ce putin conclut-elle il va mourir
des mots durs dans la bouche d'une
enfant un écho de la dureté de la guerre
et pour atténuer un peu les
bouleversements dans la vie de ces
écoliers
madame mathis leur offre toute sa
chaleur humaine
ici louis douai radio-canada vie